WORKING WITH REPUBLICANS OR WILL
GIVER UP ON BIPARTISAN TALKS.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> OHIO IS OFFERING ITS
RESIDENTS A SHOT AT WINNING $1
MILLION ALONG WITH THEIR COVID
VACCINE SHOTS.
GOVERNOR MIKE DeWINE ANNOUNCED
THAT BEGINNING MAY 26th, THE
STATE WILL DRAW ONE VACCINE
RECIPIENT TO WIN $1 MILLION.
THIS WILL HAPPEN EVERY WEEK FOR
FIVE WEEKS.
TO QUALIFY YOU HAVE TO LIVE IN
OHIO, BE 18 OR OLDER, AND HAVE
AT LEAST ONE DOSE OF THE COVID
VACCINE.
OHIO GOVERNOR MIKE DeWINE JOINS
US FIRST ON "CBS THIS MORNING."
GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
WHY THIS INCENTIVE?
>> YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN THINKING
EVERY DAY WHAT CAN WE DO TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING THE VACCINE.
AND JUST DECIDED THAT THIS MIGHT
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD KIND OF
PERSUADE SOME PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, FRAN, MY WIFE AND I
HAVE BEEN TRAVELING AROUND THE
STATE AND TALKING TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE GETTING VACCINATED.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
SEE IS THAT THERE'S SOME PEOPLE
WHO JUST WERE HOLDING BACK AND
THEN THEIR RELATIVE TALKED THEM
INTO IT, THEIR SPOUSE TALKED
THEM INTO IT, OR IT BECAME
AVAILABLE, THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
SET UP AN APPOINTMENT.
SO WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT --
NEVER GOING TO GET IT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE, 42% OF OHIOANS
NOW HAVE ALREADY GOT IT.
THEN WE'VE GOT THE -- WHAT I
CALL THE PERSUADABLES IN THE
MIDDLE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST GETTING THEM
TO DO IT.
SOME OF THEM MAY EVENTUALLY DO
IT.
BUT GETTING PEOPLE TO BE
VACCINATED NOW AS OPPOSED TO A
MONTH OR TWO MONTHS FROM NOW
WILL CERTAINLY SLOW THIS VIRUS
DOWN.
AND ULTIMATELY THIS IS GOING TO
SAVE LIVES.
>> WERE THERE NUMBERS YOU SAW
THAT SUGGESTED THIS WAS THE
RIGHT STRATEGY?
BECAUSE I KNOW ONE STUDY SHOWS
INCENTIVES ONLY INCREASE
VACCINATIONS BY AROUND 8% WHICH
COULD MAKE THIS A VERY EXPENSIVE
GAMBLE.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY WAY TO
CALCULATE IT.
I MEAN, ONE STUDY SHOWED THAT,
YOU KNOW, $100 PER PERSON WAS
MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN $25.
NO ONE HAS TRIED THIS.
WE JUST THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
WORTH TO TRY THIS TO DO IT.
AND YOU KNOW, WE JUST KNOW THAT
THIS VIRUS IS STILL VERY MUCH
OUT THERE IN OHIO.
WE'VE MADE REAL GOOD PROGRESS,
OUR CASES ARE COMING DOWN.
BUT AT THE VERY END, AS YOU
KNOW, IT'S OUT THERE AND -- THE
VARIANT, AS YOU KNOW, IT'S OUT
THERE AND MUCH MORE CONTAGIOUS
THAN IT'S EVER BEEN.
WE'VE GOT TWO GROUPS OF PEOPLE,
42% OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED AND ARE FREE.
THEY CAN GO DO WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO.
YOU HAVE THE OTHER GROUP OF
PEOPLE, THOUGH, WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED, AND THE DANGER TO
THEM IS EVEN MORE GREAT IN SOME
RESPECTS THAN IT HAS BEEN IN THE
PAST BECAUSE THIS VARIANT IS
MORE CONTAGIOUS.
>> WELL, GOVERNOR, YOU'RE
PROBABLY GETTING AN A FOR
CREATIVITY BUT AN F FOR HUH, IS
THIS THE RIGHT THING TO DO?
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S
COMING -- THE MONEY IS COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL PANDEMIC RELIEF
DOLLARS.
AND YOU'RE GETTING BIPARTISAN
CRITICISM ON BOTH SIDES.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE THAT
SAY THIS IS NOT THE BEST USE OF
THS MONEY AT THIS PARTICULAR
TIME?
>> WELL, THIS IS MONEY THAT WE
GOT FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO FIGHT THE VIRUS.
AND THERE'S NOTHING MORE POTENT
AT THIS TIME TO FIGHT THE VIRUS.
THE ONLY GAME IN TOWN REALLY AT
THIS POINT IS THE VACCINE.
AND EVERYBODY THAT WE CAN GET
VACCINATED, IT FIGHTS THE VIRUS
BETTER.
YOU KNOW, SOME PEOPLE -- I
TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST NIGHT
WHEN I EXPLAINED THIS TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF OHIO, AND
I SAID I KNOW I'LL BE
CRITICIZED.
I KNOW THERE WILL BE SOME PEOPLE
WHO SAY, WELL, THAT'S A WASTE.
WHAT I THINK IS A WASTE IS WHEN
WE HAVE A VACCINE THAT WILL SAVE
A LIFE AND SOMEONE STILL GETS
THE COVID AND DIES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN VACCINATED.
THAT'S WHAT THE WASTE IS.
THAT IS A TRAGIC, TRAGIC WASTE.
>> GOVERNOR, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT SOMETHING ONE OF YOUR
FELLOW OHIO REPUBLICANS SAID ON
THIS BROADCAST THIS MORNING.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN BASICALLY
SAID THAT YOU CANNOT DISAGREE
WITH MR. TRUMP AND LEAD THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE SAW HOUSE REPUBLICANS OUST
LIZ CHENEY THIS WEEK FROM THE
LEADERSHIP.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT,
AND DO YOU FEEL YOU STILL FIT IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> OH, I VERY MUCH FIT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A PARTY ABOUT
OPPORTUNITY.
IF THERE'S ONE THING THAT HOLDS
US TOGETHER IT'S OUR DESIRE TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY
OHIO AN, EVERY AMERICAN, SO THEY
CAN LIVE UP TO THEIR GOD-GIVEN
POTENTIAL.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S A PARTY OF
DONALD TRUMP?
DO YOU -- GOVERNOR, DO YOU THINK
IT'S PARTY OF DONALD TRUMP?
>> I THINK IT'S A PARTY OF
LIBERTY.
I THINK IT'S A PARTY OF FREEDOM.
I THINK IT'S A PARTY OF
OPPORTUNITY.
>> BUT -- BUT YOU SAW LIZ CHENEY
GET OUSTED BECAUSE SHE
CRITICIZED THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I SPENT 20 YEARS IN
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
I'M NOT THERE NOW.
I'VE GOT ENOUGH TO WORRY ABOUT
HERE IN OHIO FIGHTING THE VIRUS
AND MOVING OHIO FORWARD.
FRANKLY, I'M FOCUSED ON THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
LOOK, YOU KNOW, I HAVE RESPECT
FOR LIZ CHENEY.
I HAVE RESPECT FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
IS RIGHT NOW, AND THAT'S TO
FIGHT THE VIRUS, GET OHIO MOVING
FORWARD, PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE.
>> ALL RIGH